Welcome back everyone, It's Charlie
Dave Filoni
and the cast of Ahsoka have been talking about season
two, posting a bunch of footage and scenes recently.
I know there's been a ton of questions
about young Ahsoka coming back for more live action
Clone Wars flashbacks.
Probably one of the best parts of season one.
So we'll break it all down.
There are a lot of things Dave
Filoni has revealed about what their plans
are for the future of all these characters.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
There are about three Star Wars
series that are coming throughout 2024.
I'll talk about them later in the video
because it won't be Ahsoka season two.
It'll be a little while before that actually happens.
Same thing for the Mandalorian Season four.
Like they're getting ready to start
filming The Mandalorian Season four.
It's still going to be a while
before we actually see those episodes.
But recently you probably saw the Dave Filoni
Super Post with a big info dump
on the state of the Star Wars universe right now.
He was basically revealing
that he'd been promoted inside Lucasfilm
and he was sort of like this
creative overseer of all Star Wars stories now,
which we basically assumed
that he'd already become a long time ago.
They just formalized that the last couple of years.
sort of like a Kevin Vigor
type of figure inside the Star Wars universe.
but inside Dave Filoni post
when he was talking about all that,
he mostly talked about the future of the Mando verse,
which is like all the stuff happening on the Ahsoka
series, the stuff on The Mandalorian,
the Thrawn movie that he's supposed to be directing
in the Skeleton Crew series, like all of those series
that are connected in that part of the timeline.
But Because his job is overseeing all Star Wars
creatively now
he's handling all the stuff that's happening
in the live action movies
and the different parts of the timeline, too.
But those are all separate
from what's happening on The Mandalorian and the Sokka
his super post and everything the cast has been saying
is like all over the map, just in general.
But together they've all kind of given away
the direction that most of this is headed,
like where they're heading with Ahsoka season
to the future of these characters.
For the most part, Dave Filoni revealed
they are planning on Ahsoka season 2
as well as Rosario Dawson.
Like,
I feel pretty sure we're getting Ahsoka Season two.
They're couple issues that they have to correct
with the way that they told season one.
I'll address that later in the video.
They're like a couple of clear complaints
that people had, even people that loved season one.
Like there's still a couple of issues
that they need to address interview,
they didn't completely spoil
what's happening during season two.
They basically say that all the story threads
that they set up, like a lot of the really clear stuff
that they set up at the end of season one,
they will continue during season two.
some of that they'll continue on other series
like The Mandalorian Season four and the Thrawn movie
though too as well.
Like not all of it
will just be on a single season two In.
Thankfully, after the season one finale, Dave
Filoni did clarify what some of the ending scenes
meant for some of the characters
or what he intended for them to mean.
one of the things he talked about specifically was
bringing back Hayden Christensen as different versions
of Annie and Skywalker in different types of scenes,
even though technically it was meant to be the same.
Anakin Skywalker
just revealing himself to a Ahsoka in different ways,
in different forms,
first it was inside the world between worlds.
Then later in the series is a regular force ghost.
if it wasn't clear, it was always meant to be the same.
Anakin Skywalker
speaking or watching Ahsoka in both episodes
as he exists now in force ghost form
Anakin and any other force
ghost like Yoda or Obi-Wan Kenobi
could do what Anik and Skywalker did with Ahsoka
throughout the series.
probably one of the best parts of season
one was getting the live action
Clone Wars flashbacks with the younger
Ahsoka, played by Ariana Greenblatt.
Most of you remember her as younger, more from Avengers
Infinity War.
She was also just in the Barbie movie
without any special makeup effects.
Like this is what she looks like
without all of her makeup on.
she just posted a whole bunch of scenes
and videos with her and the other cast members,
particularly Hayden Christensen,
doing an action and young Ahsoka stuff.
It's all great to see. I wish they post more of it.
they're getting really meta here,
especially when she's standing
with like the older Rosario Dawson version of Ahsoka.
So after young Ahsoka's debut, of course,
everyone was asking when she's coming back to like,
why aren't they doing a full live action
Clone Wars TV series with her and Anna?
Can Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi all the time?
Like, why don't you just do an entire series?
There's just this the really easy answer for
that is mostly budget
and they already did the Clone Wars TV series.
It just happens to be animated.
The funny thing about that
most people don't realize this is that Lucasfilm
almost lost money on the Clone Wars TV series.
Like they weren't really making money on it
because George Lucas was funding it out of pocket
and they spent so much money on the budget.
if you go back and you watch the episodes
and then compare them to the Star Wars Rebels episodes,
you can kind of tell the budget on Star Wars Rebels
was way smaller than the budget on the Clone Wars.
part of that was because when Disney did Star Wars
Rebels, they actually wanted to make money on it.
And when George Lucas did the clone boards like before
that, he just wanted to make a really amazing series.
It didn't care about how much money they made on it.
you can kind of tell during the live action
Ahsoka episodes that they spent
a ton of money doing those Kunwar flashbacks,
even as small as they were
like they blew a ton of their budget doing that,
even though it was totally worth it.
doing a full live action
Clone Wars TV series would be like doing a Star Wars
movie every single week with that level of budget.
Every single week.
Like you thought Game of Thrones
in House of the Dragon had expensive
episodes like 10 to $12 million per episode.
Imagine hundred million dollars per episode.
so I don't think they're going to do
any kind of live action Clone Wars for TV series.
But yes,
they do plan to bring young Ahsoka back in live action.
Like, of course, they're going to bring her back
along with Anakin because it's critical
to a large part of what's happening during Ahsoka,
not just the young Ahsoka scenes in the flashbacks,
but also the present day storyline with Balance School
and what he plans to do.
Because they try to do slightly different things
With each new season
of The Mandalorian, for instance,
they're probably going to do the same thing with Ahsoka.
So we get more young Ahsoka in the future.
It'll probably be them showing scenes
from Ahsoka's life flashbacks
that they haven't done in any medium yet before.
And there is a lot of the Sophia's back story
that has not been covered yet.
Dave Filoni also made some key changes
to the way they explained the world between worlds.
So yes,
Ahsoka can also still travel there in the future.
So the way they presented young Ahsoka
on a serious season one is that
it was really just the consciousness of older Ahsoka
in the younger Ahsoka's body.
when Ariana Greenblatt was playing young Ahsoka,
she was still the older version of Ahsoka.
so they still haven't actually done
a young version of Ahsoka playing young Ahsoka.
They can do that with flashbacks in season two,
part of the idea with the way
the World Between Worlds works, like this
whole concept of time travel in the Star Wars universe.
Even though Dave Filoni himself
tries to say that it's not about time
travel, he's kind of right
the way that he talks about it.
part of the idea
is they say it's more of a metaphysical place
that your consciousness travels through,
not your physical body.
So when Ahsoka was time traveling,
so to speak, like she was kind of time traveling,
it was really just her consciousness inside her
younger body.
That's why the younger Ahsoka
remembered everything from present day.
Like, Wait a minute, things didn't go down this way.
Like you weren't here when this was happening.
What's going on?
that's why she got so confused in those final scenes
with Anakin Skywalker
like he wasn't there during that battle
because he was back on course.
On saving Emperor Palpatine
because it was the beginning of Revenge of the Sith.
but one of the big things that Dave Filoni did reveal
is that they plan
on continuing balance schools storyline,
where they left off with him
on the statues of the mortis gods
looking out over the beacon in the distance.
Now, he didn't spoil too much about his story.
He didn't specifically say
whether or not they would recast
the balance school character
because Ray Stevenson did pass away in real life.
May he rest in peace.
He was fantastic during the season.
but all that storyline that they set up was so critical
to the future of what's happening
in this part of the timeline.
Just in general,
like even on the Mandalorian series, that they wouldn't
just leave that as some big cliffhanger.
They never addressed.
in essentially balan
school said that he saw the beginning
of all think that the beginning of the force itself.
I think what he meant is
that he sought to find the source of the force,
like the beginning of the force,
which would be connected to the mortis realm.
You could also say it's connected to the world
between worlds as well, to so one of the reasons
why and can Skywalker
so critical to that storyline is because he's serving
as sort of like a guardian of the force
keeping the cosmos,
so to speak, like the grand universe itself in balance.
I did a video while season one was still airing
about how Anakin is essentially
replacing the mortgage god, so to speak,
like replacing the role that they served in the force.
he's kind of like the way that Loki exists right now
in his God form at the end of Loki Season two,
watching over everything,
keeping everything in balance, so to speak.
that's actually something that the father told Anderson
that he was destined
to become back
during the Mortis episodes of the Clone Wars.
if you haven't watched those episodes,
I would recommend you check them out.
Like, you don't need to watch
every single episode of the Clone Wars.
They're just a couple of really critical ones.
In the mortise ones are some of those.
during the live action Ahsoka series,
they establish the balance school
in Issac as these two Ronin Jedi
sort of on parallel arcs, so to speak.
So I think that Dave Filoni is setting up
this grander plan that balance school has to affect
the entire universe on a massive scale by manipulating
the force itself, taking this power for himself
in ultimately it will be Ahsoka
to be the one to stop him from doing that.
so as they're going back to the mortis realm,
eventually they're like some non-canonical now,
like some expanded universe lore that gets into
this source of the force in the mortis realm.
going back to the mortis realm
would be a really easy way to do more young Ahsoka
flashbacks with younger soak up hearing with Anakin
Skywalker in his younger form
to reference their time there during the Clone Wars
episodes.
mortis is also critical to a Sophia's back story
in that she essentially died
there and was brought back to life when the daughter
sacrificed her remaining portion of her life to her.
So now in present day, Ahsoka has a portion
of the daughter's life force insider.
The same with Mirai.
The force out is the avatar of the daughter.
Like not the daughter herself.
Just an avatar for. But you get the idea.
Both of them are like the continuation of the daughter
that's why a lot of people thought early on that Ahsoka
would become another mortis.
God, the way that Aniket is replacing the more gods
it may be balance
school of thought to take their power
and kind of replace them as well.
in maybe that's why they referenced the mortis God
so heavily in all of his ending scenes.
like next stop mortis.
Dave Filoni supposedly had most of Ahsoka season
two plotted out
and partially written
before the strikes began earlier in 2023.
But the way he talked about it recently,
it sounds like there's still a lot of work to do
before they actually start filming it.
Disney also just generally delayed all the Marvel
series, the Star Wars series, all the movies
because of the strikes and because they're completely
reorganizing how they do TV series behind the scenes.
Now, their Star Wars plan for 2024 is the Acolyte
High Republic series
that's not connected to The Mandalorian or Ahsoka.
That's like its own completely separate thing
Skeleton Crew episodes are supposed to release
at the end of 2024.
Now that is an is so Mandalorian crossover show.
I'll do separate videos about that
when we get some more actual footage.
And then the bad batch season three
is supposed to happen somewhere between those series
They already confirmed The Mandalorian.
Season four
is like the next big thing they're working on.
Like all the Mandalorian Season
four crew members in the cast
members have started to marshal
and are getting ready to film episodes.
now. There's no way they could release that till 2025.
There have been all kinds of rumors about them
turning Season four into a movie right now.
I'm not going to pay attention to those
until we start hearing that from like a billion
other reliable sources in official channels,
like official announcements.
So I wouldn't worry too much about that.
they're couple big issues that they do need to fix
from Ahsoka Season one for season two in it,
mostly just doing a better job of helping new viewers
and people who didn't watch The Clone Wars or Star Wars
Rebels episodes, connecting with all those characters
They do have The Mandalorian Season four.
They have a couple of years
before Ahsoka's Season 2 would be ready
to be released to figure out a lot of that stuff.
So let me know in the comments.
How do you want them to address
some of the big complaints from Ahsoka Season 1
really excited though for them to go
super deep on Nightsisters.
Now, in this part of the timeline,
I just did another video talking a little bit more
about the Mandalorian Season 4.
Click here to learn about that and then click here
for that Star Wars Acolyte trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!